so one of the Frameworks I like to use
to overcome obstacles is hypothetical
situation get agreement and then meet
the situation this works better if
you're in service but if someone says
hey I don't like this solution because
of XYZ reason then you say if XYZ reason
weren't an issue would you do it and if
the person says yes then you say awesome
well I can accommodate that what card do
you want to use and then it's done
because they've already gotten the
agreement they've committed to saying
that if you solve that problem you do it
because they don't know that you can't
solve that problem really easily on the
flip side if they say well no then you
get to the core reason of why they
really don't want to do it and then this
often vanishes because you resolve the
real problem especially if you get
caught in a Zone you're like not sure
what to say they're like well I need to
think about it and you're like well if
you didn't need to think about it would
you do it great what would you need to
see if someone's like it's too expensive
okay well if it weren't too expensive
would you do it and it gives you a
second to catch your breath and get an
agreement at the same time from the
person and then you get into problem
solving mode which is where you want to
be rather than combative mode because
now you're on the same side of the table
and trying to solve this problem
together